same thing with um blueface no with the
other guy i could have signed him too
mozzie i i'm sure that that's
for some change yeah i mean you were to
think that that would have made sense
back then
i want to see everybody be a boss i want
to see everybody like i gave them
okay i think it's a plan like how to
become a boss like how to
run your company how to become a brand
i'm the blueprint to independent success
everybody would be like oh you could
have you could do this like on like like
it was like
come up like i'm not no type of [ __ ]
like that like i'm not hurt i don't need
it you'd rather but a lot of people say
the game is to be sold not told you
you that's and that's a wack thing to
say and so it's like bro you shoulda did
this you could have did this and that
and the way they standing like in a bad
way like
i'm like bro like i ain't trying to come
up off no [ __ ] like like
plus at the time uh he kept going to
jail
right he kept going to jail like like it
was some [ __ ] like
flashes or some [ __ ] 10 night flashes he
kept going to jail kept going to jail
but while he was down i was keeping him
alive yeah i'm saying like you could
check
um an old video i had with um
with rj and yg just went yg album at
first came out most of whatever i had to
i'm sweating on
wow yeah so and when he was down
everybody was hitting me
hey man i need a verse man he gonna be
home soon this isn't this you know
just on some genuine [ __ ] though but it
i don't i'm not looking at [ __ ] that's
come up like even with my artists i just
gave them both for rolex the other day
you know what i'm saying i gave him both
rolex i just told him like i don't want
nothing i just want y'all to keep
working
that's fire man i wish somebody would
have did that for me when i was coming
up
do you ever uh see a a world in which
you and mazzy can have a conversation in
reconcile
and we could holla that's good looking
for show hollow like it ain't
it ain't to the point like nothing has
happened to me nothing's happening it
felt like some
and we got some good rap music out of it
yeah yeah we did man look he was
snapping on your [ __ ] he was now i mean
like you know look as long as it stays
on music i'm all for
for some rat beef but it has to stay on
music that's the problem
when you look at somebody like you and
someone like mozzie i remember when it
first happened
i was like [ __ ] someone's gonna die man
you said that i remember
these are the two [ __ ] that i
don't like i wouldn't want to see
anybody before either of the others
you gotta understand too that was like
like
and then even from from a fan both i
mean when you both
like one of the dudes where you from
yeah i'm saying like
[ __ ] can't go sour you know what i'm
saying so
and at the end of that day too like
i think he's not finished i thought he
liked the way yeah i'm saying so it's
like
okay i'm gonna give you a scenario um
when he made the song the uh killed
jeremy song
he posted a picture of my house at the
time being which
it wasn't my house at the time i
remember that yeah but the next day the
police was in front of the house
i remember seeing that and being like
[ __ ] here it goes yeah
so with that being said like the
once the police get involved i just left
it alone
because like if a rockwood went through
the window and hit him in the head and
he passed out there to try to come grab
me
right right police involved i'm done
with it that's why i didn't even respond
to it after that